and now as chairman of the board of
trustees of Carnegie Mellon University I
have the distinct honor of representing
the board in the investiture of subra
Suresh the ninth president of Carnegie
Mellon University dr. Suresh will you
please come forward and join me this
parts formal mm-hmm subra Suresh by the
authority of the board of trustees and
with the enthusiastic approval of the
faculty staff students alumni and this
distinguished assembly I present into
your keeping the charter of Carnegie
Mellon University i also present to you
the Great Seal of the University the
symbol of the high office you now hold
and invest you with all the rights
privileges and responsibilities of the
office of the president may you serve
our great university with wisdom
compassion and dedication
charter congratulations
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
board of trustees and the Academy I
present to you the ninth president of
Carnegie Mellon University super Suresh
mr. Lane members of the Board of
Trustees members of the Academy I hereby
accept this charter and medallion as
symbols of the office of the president
of Carnegie Mellon University and do so
with a full understanding of the
magnitude of my responsibilities I am
deeply grateful for your trust and I
will work tirelessly with the board of
trustees faculty staff students and
alumni for the greatest good of our
institution chairman Lane dr. John
Holdren dr. Eric Schmidt dear members of
the faculty students staff colleagues
friends who have come from far and near
crossing boundaries transforming lives
in 1848 a 13 year old boy and his poor
family left their home in dunfermline
Scotland crossing boundaries and a very
large ocean to settle in the north of
Pittsburgh that journey transformed his
life and the lives of countless others
around the world that boy Andrew
Carnegie went on to build the largest
and most innovative steel company of the
19th century in his new city he devoted
the later years of his life to
extraordinary philanthropy with a focus
on what he considered as the most
important needs of his time
education research libraries the arts
and peace among nations on November
fifteenth nineteen hundred exactly one
hundred and thirteen years ago to this
day Andrew Carnegie attended a dinner in
the hotel across the street from this
place where we are right now which is
now the University of Pittsburgh student
union there he read aloud a letter to
the mayor of Pittsburgh with a proposal
to create a new kind of school in
Pittsburgh it was to be a place where
young men and young women would be given
practical training in skills for work
and life and in the arts science and
technology Carnegie ended his letter
with the phrase my heart is in the work
which became the motto of the University
that he created that we now know as
Carnegie Mellon University his vision
and philanthropy defined the unusual and
powerful educational and research
culture of Carnegie Mellon that uniquely
integrates science and technology on the
one hand with the arts and humanities on
the other standing here on the 113th
anniversary day of Carnegie's Andrew
Carnegie's proposal to create what has
now become Carnegie Mellon University I
cannot help but think about my own
journey that brought me here I am here
because of the vision and courage of a
mother who herself was not lucky enough
to go beyond high school still she
encouraged me to cross many boundaries
knowing all the
risks and personal sacrifices that she
would have to endure and knowing fully
well that my journey would transform my
life and hers forever 36 years ago I
crossed many national boundaries and
several large oceans with a partially
filled suitcase and less than one
hundred dollars in my pocket and a
one-way airline ticket purchased with a
loan to begin a new life that would
eventually bring me here to this very
place where exactly one hundred and
thirteen years ago today Andrew
Carnegie's hard work another immigrants
hard work created the university that i
am now so fortunate to lead as president
many others who were courageous enough
to cross boundaries have shaped the
culture of carnegie mellon i will
mention only a few dr. Herbert Simon was
a CMU professor a pioneer in the areas
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning and a Nobel laureate in
economics in 1956 the year I was born
Simon grasped the potential power that
computing would bring to the world he
developed this powerful idea to reshape
the University and the world including
the subsequent founding of the school of
computer science and the Heinz College
of policy Public Policy and management
and the creation of a totally new
psychology faculty focused on cognitive
neuroscience he also led by example by
embracing the powerful value of multiple
disciplinary perspectives in conducting
research that to this day enriches the
culture of teaching creativity and
discovery on this campus
Simon walked to work every day from his
house on Northumberland Street just a
mile from here where Mary and I now live
and his spirit is still very much alive
on this campus Carnegie Mellon owes much
to such scholars and pioneers we also
owe much to eight previous presidents of
Carnegie Mellon Arthur hammerschlag
Thomas Baker Robert Daugherty john
warner guy stever who after he left
Carnegie Mellon went to become the
director of the National Science
Foundation dig site Robert Mehrabian and
Jerry Cohen whose hard work and passion
for this campus have shaped its
intellectual vitality with the past
several presidents of Carnegie Mellon
this university in partnership with the
university of pittsburgh has played a
critical role in the entrepreneurial
economic and cultural rebirth of
pittsburgh the county and the region i
would like to take this opportunity to
thank my very dear friend mark
Nordenberg who's here chancellor of the
university of pittsburgh
I would like to express my profound
thanks to Ray Lane chairman of our board
of trustees and the entire board for
giving me the great opportunity to lead
this remarkable University and for the
warmth friendship and support they have
given me more than most universities
Carnegie Mellon owes much to the
visionary local philanthropist Andrew
Carnegie of course but also andrew
mellon Richard King melon paul mellon
and their descendants and foundations
the heinz family and the heinz
endowments led by teresa heinz kerry the
McEwan foundation the Eden Hall
foundation the Hillman family members
and their foundations the late build a
trick and the Dietrich foundation the
extraordinary legacy of on do Andrew
Carnegie's philanthropy continues to
this day exactly 113 years to the day
after Carnegie made his pledge to donate
funds to the city of Pittsburgh to
create this University another great
philanthropist of our era is having his
own profound impact on CMU just this
morning we announced the largest single
gift in the history of the university
from a CMU graduate to support an
infrastructure project from the
charitable foundation of CMU alumnus and
trustee David a temper his new gift
pledge is over and above his earlier
gift to the temper school of business
all now totaling more than 125 million
dollars gave it
David on behalf of the entire CMU
community I would like to thank you for
your extraordinary generosity your
commitment to CMU and you are trust in
the growing potential of this university
I am also very grateful to you for the
enormous trust you have placed in me by
announcing this very significant gift on
the day I am being inaugurated as the
president of this university the
university is also fortunate to have
some 92,000 accomplished alumni across
the globe who successes and connections
with Carnegie Mellon enrich this
university every day current members and
alumni of CMU campuses now spanned the
globe many of them are watching this
live thanks to the technology enabled by
CMU and companies like Google from
Pittsburgh to New York City to Silicon
Valley to Australia to Singapore to
Qatar to Rwanda going from the past and
the present to the future there are many
exciting possibilities perhaps even
imperatives for CMU since July I have
benefited from my listening tour in
addition to various forums around the
country and around the world meeting
with faculty students staff alumni
trustees parents and Friends of the
University the listening tour will
continue and it will provide rich input
as we work together to set to new
strategic directions and priorities for
the university I am delighted to be able
to discuss two exciting developments
coming out of the listening tour we were
fortunate to be able to announce both of
these developments during this week
first David peppers new gift will
crystallize an exciting new vision for
the new phase of evolution of the CMU
campus it will begin
the development of what we will call the
new temper quadrangle the first building
on the temper quad will not only host
the new home for the tapper school of
business but it will also strategically
co-locate a number of university-wide
activities to tap into the enormous
entrepreneurial culture of CMU data
suggests that for the last five years
CMU has created more spin-off companies
/ federal federal research dollar than
any other university in the United
States especially a university with no
medical school
in fact just last week CMU was
recognized as one of the top five
universities in the u.s. in the amount
of venture capital investment received
really astonishing for a university
that's not located in one of the top
five metropolitan areas on either coast
The Temper quad will be the university's
focal point of strategic connections for
entrepreneurship across campus both in
education and research the development
of the new tempor quad also comes at a
critical point in the economic
reemergence of the city working with the
University of Pittsburgh and the many
collaborators in the city the county and
the region Carnegie Mellon has the
opportunity to transform Forbes Avenue
into one of the most vibrant and
prominent innovation corridors in the
United States the first building on The
Temper court will exemplify CMU's
interdisciplinary culture as home to CMU
steppers business school it will provide
more and better qualities phase for
current use and future expansion it will
also how CMU center for innovation and
entrepreneurship and the center for
technology transfer and enterprise
creation and serve as a hub for
connecting CMU's Pittsburgh campuses
with its research and teaching
activities across the globe with the
latest tools the technology can offer it
will house the largest auditorium on
campus also a classroom with
possibilities for modular classrooms for
technology enhanced learning the new
building will also house a new Welcome
Center for the entire university it will
showcase the accomplishments of the
members of the CMU community present and
past this LEED Gold certified building
will also include elements that enhance
the quality of life for all members of
the campus quality gathering places for
Stu
staff and faculty space for student
projects a fitness center and a cafe it
will integrate the rich cherry heritage
of innovation and entrepreneurship from
all parts of CMU for example it will
convey the culture and ethos of this
university shaped by people such as
Andrew Carnegie Andrew Mellon Herbert
Simon and 18 other Nobel laureates who
spent part of their lives on this campus
12 Turing Prize winners in computer
science 62 members of the National
Academies eight franklin medal winners
six winners of the Academy Awards 101
Emmy Awards 35 Tony Awards John Nash
whose story was popularized by the book
and movie A Beautiful Mind artist Andy
Warhol Tony award-winning Broadway
actress cherry Jones and of course
patina Miller as CMU alumna whose
extraordinary talent we all were
fortunate to experience just a few
minutes ago the second major theme for
the future of CMU coming from the
faculty from my listening tour relates
to the other announcement we made on
Monday of this week the launch of the
Simon initiative at Carnegie Mellon
University it is created to honor the
work of herb Simon the Simon initiative
has three major components one it will
leverage CMU's leadership in developing
unique tools techniques and technologies
to enhance learning outcomes
specifically it will crystallize years
of activities at CMU through such
entities as the open learning initiative
the science of learning center jointly
administered with the University of
Pittsburgh and funded by the National
Science Foundation and the Eberly Center
for teaching
and educational innovation into a
coherent university-wide effort we will
create a new seed funding mechanism
partnering with the deeds of all the
schools and colleges at CMU to expand
the impact of CMU's rich portfolio in
using technology to improve learning
outcomes both for our students on campus
and for learners worldwide too we have
launched a new global learning council
or GLC which comprises thought leaders
in education and technology enhanced
learning the GLC is a virtual entity
that is committed to developing metrics
best practices and standards to improve
learning outcomes for the individual as
well as for millions of learners third a
large data bank that will be open to the
world will be developed as part of this
initiative to store research and analyze
information about learning and about the
outcomes of teaching of course we have
partnered with Google and Microsoft in
this effort the Simon initiative will
coordinate a taxi activities of many
faculty members from across campus and
others who will join them and from
around the world through strategic
points of convergence at the new
building to be built on the tepper quad
our College of Fine Arts was part of
Carnegie's vision for this campus since
1900 and it has a wonderful record of
contributions to American art
architecture design music film and
theater in 2012 the School of Music
celebrated its centennial next year in
2014 we will celebrate 100 years at the
School of Drama next year will also mark
the 25 years officially of the School of
Computer Science as we celebrate these
milestones I cannot help
the following questions what would
today's world be like if CMU did not
create it School of Computer Science in
fact I asked Eric earlier what would
google be like CMU did not create the
School of Computer Science what would
the world of fine arts and entertainment
be today if Carnegie Mellon did not
create its top ranked school of drama
100 years ago art and Technology at CMU
are interconnected parts of a whole so
our business and public policy these are
all our signature strengths the
humanities behavioral sciences and
Social Sciences further strengthened and
Hendricks this uniquely creative
intellectual portfolio and from
languages to philosophy to statistics to
psychology our scholars have made
collaboration and connection a part of
their mission there are many
technological challenges and solutions
facing us in the 21st century adapting
to global change coping with infectious
diseases devising new ways to preserve
clean water use of computation and big
data to improve health and education
while preserving privacy and
confidentiality these are technological
challenges that will demand the best in
engineering and natural sciences working
together but they are also human
challenges they require serious
consideration of the human condition we
cannot meaningfully confront human
challenges without bringing balance
perspectives from the humanities Fine
Arts social behavioral and economic
sciences to address them CMU's unique
strengths in bringing different
disciplines together is just one aspect
of our diversity in addition gender
ratio ethnic and national origin
diversity is essential for much greater
impact when people with different life
experiences come together to work on a
common problem they see the same issue
from different vantage points and they
correct one other one another's hidden
biases therefore diversity in all human
and disciplinary dimensions
intrinsically enhances innovation
whereas 113 years after the founding of
this great institution we continue to
echo our founder statement my heart is
in the work let us also recommit
ourselves to the human dimension that
underpins and energizes our goals
aspirations and actions let us also say
today and everyday my work is from the
heart I thank all of you from CMU and
Pittsburgh for so warmly embracing and
welcoming my family and me to this
wonderful city I also wish to take this
opportunity to thank my companion and
friend in this journey and my wife of 27
years Mary without whose love support an
extraordinary generosity I would not be
here today thank
I would also like to thank our two
daughters Nina and Mira my sister Chitra
and all our family members and friends
who have joined us here today thank you
very much
you